c'est toi ça bientôt c'est squeeze
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec mecha
sur arte voilà on va plus tard mon gars
c'est chiant que tu as on va faire de la
viande le grand là parce que là on va
vraiment appel grand lui met des coups
dans sa cave
il va me mais non mais non c'est moi
confiance elle t'a fils de chiens chats
oiseaux et la gtz accueil n'est pas
content il ya des baies empoisonné ou
pas parce que des fois je les prends et
d'un coup je m'endors c'est normal non
chez lesquels ben je sais pas des fois
je bouffe et d'un coup on perçoit il
s'endort à cesser les blanches mon gars
tu as un corse et aux rimes temps
j'arrive thé où je vois paillade la
brume [ __ ] les cheveux juste à côté je
te vois pour y cultiver chez tes août et
sous voilà non même pas mais non mais je
suis là où la queue grosse merde va j'ai
bien vieux bateau la pause et koné je
suis là non si j'ai entendu un p c'est
quoi ces dix qui sont immatures là les
vrais rendra en seraient créés dans la
vraie vie un peu dans le pote qui pète
mais causent pas le dire quoi la
personne est battu c'est qu'on veut
monter la colline obame hourriya
pâtirait que j'irai avec non tu mens ya
un dino qui dépasse du mur monga déjà ya
dino regarde on le gardait les stores et
cohabitent elle a fait des études dans
le 10 novembre ça se dégonfle aux russes
4 8 2 vraiment craint rien une espèce
qui mangent beaucoup de phoques
essentiellement fait qu'ils voient que
la prime oise et avec 2 caresses sur le
nez j'ai pas aimé un endroit pour
rentrer on peut pas casser la cette
porte là on la casse à coups de hache
n'a ici bienvenue en plus le bienvenu
ouais bah bienvenue blard merde de
quelques excuses mais quelqu'un part on
s'est trompé de maison ont pensé
steicher nous la rejetons dans le doute
mais il va envoyer sur le direct
aillagon bic a fait pas lourd c'est eu
égard on est nouveau on vient en paix
non non mais on n'a personne personne
n'a tapé sur cette maison
bah oui on regarde elle est en pleine
forme raison oitation fait pas le con
carlos genève les cadeaux
[Musique]
c'est la dap et mon gars il a tu vas te
bouffer chez les noirs qu'il faut pas
manger s'il faut les manger ses dépens
après je me suis endormi dans l'eau à
l'entraînement on dit qu'il est mort à
témoin la terre n'est plus de toi si tu
es match je tiens toi bien géré on voit
pas ce qu'il fait à bramois notre corps
quoi c'est hyper stressant j'vois
ghislaine ont bougé mais je veux pas
savoir
[ __ ] viendront manger une baignoire
après les ménages c'est ce qui donne le
plus de goût après baignoire on peut se
laver aussi donner tort et moi qui
depuis gestede la vie mais c'est bon
[ __ ] heureusement que j'étais là bas
si tu creuses shimane chiffrait [ __ ]
il bat chip et pourquoi tf1 cheveux
qu'on a bah je sais pas mais j'ai mangé
la viande est un [ __ ] mais toi voilà
ce que j'en fait on peut voir à rethel
fais pas le con tu fais pas le con
tentera de vous rien de la viande avec
ton corps tu peux faire ça oui tu m'as
donné six de viande
[Musique]
mais y'a un mec en face aux gros il est
sûr à y mener sur un dino dégageait pas
foreign media a coupé 3 doigts à itunes
est fait maison le cas a dit qu'elle
attend bizarrement c'est là même qu'on
vient trouver exactement pareil des quoi
dedans
alstom raciale et là oh pardon mec tu
match oui non tu mens iard attendait à
toi de toi je suis moi non tu mens
[Musique]
oya deux gars sur le raptor la base
mécanique à il arrive bekaert est mort
mika je te jure t morts je suis en a je
te jure t morts je suis une fougère
bonjour monsieur la fougère plus grosse
que moi je range délicatement mon arme
et je me mets à genoux
pardon pardon pardon pardon je débute un
jeu trompé tout le bordel quand on est
obèse qui est comique à caen ces
passages axxon c'était une blague
on rigolait entre fougères yazid ont
protégé d'eau je crois qu'ils ont [ __ ]
au mercy on nous fait un tiers qu en
échange de votre protection a cassé vous
ne vous protège et ce sera parfait
direct et s'accouplent avec n'importe
quoi à l'eag a dit mathieu nom est
assommé mais comment ça désolé tu m'as
sauvé
arrête de jouer avec mon corps dit donc
si on prend de me faire de mal à nouer
des relations et des papas et elle me
tape pas je vais mourir papac et bhiwani
cab a insulté ya qu'une bouche cuite le
franc est bien dans les bons steaks papa
tu vas faire quoi
pas de grosse paire doit faire quoi il
m'a tué papa je vous fais plus confiance
papa et frérot
moi je suis petit et maigre et j'ai pas
le droit de le taper c'est sa droite
merci papa
voilà voilà by jove tapez vous l'avez
est tournée maintenant comment tuer deux
personnes beaucoup plus forte que toi
viens d'un coup on n'atteint pas lui la
suite immobile je t'aime papa papa je
rigolais je parle de bouchons le caillou
vous pourrez rien de faire vasiliev
stator masi et ba et ba je retourne sur
la plage
tu veux un steak si tu veux un steak
tiens voilà au delà bien on a perdu mon
copain au basket est tout seul tu fais
quoi maintenant
ah bah tu me tues
france à toute l'équipe il m'a dit
attention avec ce jouet était prêt à
temps on est tellement des enfants
regardent ils vont me tuer mais ils sont
trop bas
à quelques heures avant un jour ajout à
1 2 3 soleil ça ou va les conseils des
constructeurs dans les bons veaux arbres
qu'elle va le faire sont dino va il fait
son dîner au alors oui et là c'est parti
pour le plan qui va sûrement raté 1 2 3
soleil ok 1 2 3 soleil pas mal tu me dis
quand je sors un peu trop bas tu as
triché et aux montées sur les chars pas
rater et ma légion ces dix en fin de
cette deuxième vidéo sur arc avec mika
j'espère qu'il vous a plu si ces cas
n'hésitez pas à l'ailé comme d'habitude
on se fera peut-être une troisième vidéo
dessus avec mika une dernière qu'on aura
vraiment beaucoup de ce fou quoi ça
pourrait être marrant mais savoir
regarder portez vous bien que tout le
monde pousse
[Musique]
oh